Transcriber: Sara Ozturk
Gözden geçirme: Ömer Faruk Zeren
Ben size Narkissos’un hikayesini
anlatmaya geldim.
Narkissos’tan Nergis’e nasıl geçeceğimizi
sizinle paylaşmaya geldim.
Narkissos,
yakışıklılığıyla, karizmasıyla,
cool görüntüsüyle
birçok taliplinin ilgisini çeken
ama kendisine olan
aşırı sevgisinden dolayı
hiç kimseye de iltifat etmeyen,
yüz vermeyen bir Yunan
mitolojik karakteridir.
O kadar çok kalp kırar ki
en sonunda Echo adlı
son derece güzel, efendi bir bayanı
dahi kırmaktan geri durmaz.
Echo
kendi sesini kaybedip
başkalarının söylediklerini
tekrar etmeye mahkum edilen
bir karakter olmasına rağmen,
bugün Batı dillerinde ve Türkçede de Echo
kelimesi oradan geliyor.
Narkissos’un ilgisine mazhar olamaz.
Sevgisine, aşkına, sevdasına karşılık
bulamadığı için hastalanır, ölür.
Ölürken eriyen kemikleri dağ, geriye
kalan nefesi bir yankı olur.
Gökler bu duruma çok kızarlar ve
Narkissos’u cezalandırmaya karar verirler.
Bir gün Narkissos, bir nehrin kenarında
su içmek için eğildiğinde
suda kendi aksini görür.
Kendini gördüğü anda kendine aşık olur.
Ama bu aşkın da
bir karşılığı olmayacağı için
kendisine olan aşkı nedeniyle
yavaş yavaş ölür.
Suya düştüğü yerde bir çiçek biter.
O çiçeğin adı Nergis idir.
Nergis göbeği sarı,
etrafı beyaz yapraklardan oluşan
ama fiziki endamı ile
boynu bükük olduğu için alçak gönüllülüğü
temsil eden çiçektir.
Narkissos’un kendine olan aşırı sevgisi,
öz sevgisi, kibre varan
kendine öz güveninin
nergis formunda tekrar
ortaya çıkışının hikayesidir bu.
Nergis yüzyıllar boyunca gelin
çiçeği olarak bilinir.
Sevgi çiçeği olarak bilinir.
Ama bunların ötesinde tevazunun,
alçak gönüllülüğün sembolü olarak bilinir.
Narkissos’un  temel sorunu,
kendine olan sevgisini mutlaklaştırarak
etrafındaki hiçbir güzelliği
göremez hale gelmesidir.
Bu modern psikolojide psikanalizde
narsisist kişilik bozukluğu olarak
karşımıza çıkar.
Diğer unsurları arasında iki
yönü dikkate değerdir.
Birincisi kendini aşırı beğenme,
alemdeki diğer güzellikleri
görememe derecesinde
sadece ve sadece kendini
beğenme duygusudur.
İkincisi de bir beğenilme açlığı eder.
Asla tatmin edilemeyen, doyurulamayan
bir beğenilme açlığıdır.
Bu iki sorunla karşı karşıya olan kişiler
her zaman mutsuzdurlar.
Çünkü insan tabiatına aykırı bir
ilişki biçimi içerisindedirler.
Zira insan ancak kendisi dışındaki
varlıklarla, insanlarla, tabiatla,
evrenle ilişki kurabildiği, onlarla çoğu
alabildiği, onlarla ünsiyet yani bir bağ
kurabildiği oranda insandır.
Nitekim insan kelimesi Arapçada köken
olarak iki manaya geri gider.
Birincisi “ne-se-ye ” kökünden unutmaktır.
İnsan unutan varlıktır.
Ama ikinci manası ″ En, es, e ″
eski kökünden gelir.
Ünsiyet ve bağ kurabilen varlık demektir.
Başkalarıyla, varlık alemiyle, başka
insanlarla, kendisi gibi olmayanlarla
hepsinin ötesinde
yaradanıyla bağ kurabilen,
ünsiyet kurabilen
varlık demektir.
Nitekim dilimize de geçen Enes, Enis gibi
isimlerin manası da insanın bu ünsiyet
kurabilme niteliğiyle ilgilidir.
İnsan kendi dışına çıkabildiği, kendi
nefsini aşabildiği , kendinin ötesine
gidebildiği oranda hakikatini
keşfedebilen bir varlıktır.
Tohum toprağa atılır ki kendinden çıksın.
Kök budak salsın, ağaç olsun.
Toprağın altından çıkıp semaya
doğru yükselsin.
Kendinde kalan, kendinde
tükenmeye mahkumdur.
O yüzden insan,
narsisizm den uzaklaştığı oranda
etrafındaki alemdeki güzellikleri,
manaları, sırları,
tınıları, melodileri, mesajları duymaya,
görmeye ve hissetmeye başlar.
Modern dönemde Kartezyen dönüşüm dediğimiz
16 ve 17. yüzyıldaki
büyük felsefi kırılmadan beri, insanlık
olarak kendimizi evrenin merkezinde,
alemin merkezinde
ona mana ve önem atfeden,
aşılayan tek varlık olarak kurguladık.
Halbuki insan evrenin efendisi değildir.
Evrenin sahibi değildir.
Olsa olsa onun bir parçasıdır.
Onun bir yoldaşıdır.
Onun bir dostudur.
Onun bir paydaşıdır.
İnsan, evrenle böyle bir ilişki
kurabildiği, böyle bir ünsiyet
bağ kurabildiği oranda ona efendilik
taslamak dan vazgeçer,
onun hamisi olur, onun koruyucusu olur,
onun sırdaşı olur, onun yoldaşı olur.
Bunu yapabildiği oranda da alem,
varlık alemi, tabiat alemi
ona konuşmaya başlar.
Ve insan dinlemenin, duymanın sadece
fiziki kulakla değil,
akıl ile, sezgiyle, kalp ile, hayal ile,
hülasa insanın bütün varlığıyla, bütün
kognitif fakülteleri ile birlikte
gerçekleşen bir eylem olduğunu
o zaman kavramaya başlar.
Çağının en büyük bilgesi, Sokrat;
″ Tek bildiğim hiçbir şey bilmediğimdir.″
dediğinde aslında tam da sofistler de
gördüğü kendilerini
evrenin merkezine koyma
eğilimine bir isyan,
bir haykırış ile karşılık vermekteydi.
Sokrat gibi bir bilgenin
sadece malumat anlamında değil,
gerçek bilgi anlamında,
hikmet anlamında, irfan anlamında, ben
bilgisi anlamında hakikatin yüksek
mertebelerine ulaşmış bir insan olarak tek
bildiğim hiçbir şey bilmediğimdir demesi
tabii ki bir ironiden daha fazlasını
ifade ediyor idi.
Döneminde bilgiyi araçsallaştıran,
metalaştıran, bildiğini
para karşılığı satan
ve amaca götüren her araç meşrudur
diyen sofistler karşı
Sokrat, bilginin asaletini, bilginin
kendi zatında ki kıymetini ve
kutsallığını savunuyordu.
Bunun için de onlara bir ironi yaparak
sizin bildikleriniz bilgi değil.
Bunlar malumat dan ibaret diyor idi.
Sokrat bunu derken Delfi tapınağının
hemen girişinde
″ Gnothi seauton ″ kendini bil!
sözüne atıf yapıyordu.
″Gnothi ″ kelimesinin Yunanca’da
bu şekilde kullanılması da çok manidar.
Zira daha sonra Batı dillerine Latince
üzerinden geçecek olan
Gnosis kelimesi de
aynı Sanskritçedeki ″Jinana ″gibi bir şeyi
arifane bir şekilde bilmek.
Hakikatiyle, derinlemesine bilmek
ve kavramak anlamına gelir.
Epistemenin ötesinde, yani sıradan bir
malumat anlamında bilmenin ötesinde,
insanın bir şeyi hakikatiyle derinlemesine
bilmesi ve o bilgiyi
kendinde gerçekleştirmesini ifade eder.
Bizim felsefe geleneğimize
Yunan tercümeler yapılmaya başladığında da
Gnothi ile ilgili olan
Gnothsis kelimeleri de
doğrudan irfan olarak çevrilir.
Yani arifane bir şekilde bilmek.
O yüzden de arifler ″Kendini bil″ sözünün
tahakkuk etmiş canlı örnekleridir.
Kendini bil demek,
elbette egonu büyüt demek,
kendini gel alemin merkezine
koy demek değildir.
Tam tersine alemin içerisindeki
yerini bil demektir.
Kendini, özünü , nefsini,
öz kimliğini bil demek,
insanın varlık hiyerarşisi ve
büyük varlık dairesi içerisindeki yerini
doğru tespit etmesi demektir.
Ama bu sadece sıradan manada
bir bilmek değildir.
Çünkü gerçek manada bilmek,
bulmak demektir.
Ve nitekim hem Latince de hem Arapça da
var olmak, varlık kelimeleri
hem ″ Exsistere ″
hem de vücûd kelimesi köken itibarıyla
bulmak ve bulunmak demektir.
Var olmak bulmaktır.
Ancak bulanlar gerçek manada vardırlar.
Bulamayanlar olsa olsa mevcut olabilirler.
Özne olamazlar.
Nesne olabilirler.
Fiziki olarak var olabilirler.
Ama “Existansiel” manada, varoluşsal
manada bir varlık ortaya koyamazlar.
O yüzden bilmek bulmaktır.
Bulmak, var olmaktır.
Kendini bil demek, kendini bul demektir.
Kendini bul, evrendeki yerini bul.
Her şeyi yerli yerine oturt.
Bunu yapan insan aleme bir kibir
ve gurur gözüyle bakamaz.
Narsisistik bir perspektiften bakamaz.
Kendisini o büyük gerçekliğin
bir parçası olarak görür.
Varlık alemiyle, eşyayla, tabiat alemiyle,
diğer varlıklarla, diğer insanlarla
kavga etmekten vazgeçer.
Onların varlığını kendisine
bir tehdit olarak görmez.
Tam tersine onları kendi gerçekliğini
tahakkuk ettirebileceği
kendi hakikatini ortaya çıkartabileceği
bir ayna olarak görür,
bir yoldaş olarak görür.
Onlarla birlikte var olmanın,
çoğalmanın yollarını arar.
Bu öylesine önemli bir konudur ki,
insanın kendini üstün görmesi
bireysel manada bencilliğe,
kolektif manada insanı ırkçılığa götürür.
Kendi ırkını, kendi etnik kökenini
üstün görmek,
başkalarına karşı ırkçılığa dönüşür.
Narsisizmin ötesinde, bireysel
bencilliğin ötesinde
kolektif bir faciaya götürür.
Nitekim tarihte, modern dönemde karşımıza
çıkan ırkçı hareketlerin hepsinin
kökeninde kolektif bir üstünlük
duygusu vardır.
Ben varım, benim kolektif kimliğim var,
gerisi hepsi bana hizmet etmek için
araçsal olarak var olan şeylerdir,
nesnelerdir.
Tarihin aşamalarıdır diye bakarlar.
İlginçtir, tarihteki ilk ırkçı şeytandır.
Çünkü Cenab-ı Hak bütün meleklere Adem’i
yarattım, şimdi ona secde edin dediğinde
ayette anlatıldığı şekliyle
söyleyecek olursak,
şeytan, kibirlendi ve dedi ki,
″ Onu topraktan, beni ateşten yarattın,
ben ondan üstünüm,
o yüzden ona secde etmeyeceğim. ″ der.
Ve ırkçılığın hikayesi aslında şeytanın
benim ırkım, benim ateşim onun
toprağından daha üstündür diyerek başlar.
Irkçılık bu manada lanetlenmiştir.
Hem bireysel hem kolektif manada
insana ve topluma,
″ Haddinizi bilin, sınırınızı bilin. ″
denmiştir.
Kadim bilgeliğin bize öğrettiği hakikat,
bu manada insanın kendi yerini bilmesini,
alçak gönüllü ve mütevazi olmasını,
sadece bir bireysel tercih
yahut bir ahlaki norm değil,
ontolojik bir zaruret olduğunu öğretir.
Bu öylesine güçlü bir ilkedir,
umdedir, öğretidir ki
yine Peygamber Efendimiz bir hadisinde,
″ Kalbinde zerre miktarı kibir olan
cennete giremeyecektir. ″ der
Zira dünyada şunları , bunları vesaire
yapmış olsanız da içinizde taşıdığınız
bir zerre miktarı kibir sizi hem kendi
gerçekliğinizden, hem alemin yaratılış
manasından ve maksadının uzaklaştırır.
Bu öylesine temel bir ilkedir ki,
Peygamber Efendimizin hayatında beni en
çok çarpan, sarsan sahnelerden bir
tanesi çok basit,
çok kısa gerçekleşmiş bir hadisedir.
Bir gün Peygamber Efendimiz ashabıyla,
arkadaşıyla bir yerde otururken,
Peygamber Efendimizle henüz vücahen,
ruhberuh, yüz yüze hiç tanışmamış ,
onu görmemiş birisi biraz da hışımla gelir
şöyle bir o meclise bakar,
″ Muhammed hanginiz? ″ der.
Kıssa bundan ibarettir.
Oturma düzenlerinde, kılık kıyafetlerinde,
ilişkilerinde o kadar eşit,
o kadar mütevazi bir haldedirler ki,
dışarıdan gelen birisi
peygamberin kim olduğunu söyleyemez,
ayırt edemez.
″ Muhammed hanginiz? ″ sorusu,
(Alkış)
hepimizi aslında varlığımızın özünden,
kökeninden sarsıp ayağa kaldırması
ayağa kaldırması gereken bir sorudur.
Bu ilke, insanın alemdeki yerini,
başka varlıklarla olan
ilişkisini tanımlarken,
bizim kendimize ilişkin,
kendini keşfetme serüvenimiz ile ilgili de
bize önemli ilkeler önemli işaretler sunar
Elbette insanın kendini bilmesi,
egosunu yüceltmesi, ilahlaştırması,
mutlaklaştırması demek değildir.
Günümüzün beğeni çağında
her şeyin sosyal medyada
bir beğeni toplama kaç beğeni aldın
sorusu üzerine kurulu olduğu bir
çağda bu mesele üzerinde
tekrar düşünmemiz gerekiyor.
Bir hız ve haz çağında yaşadığımız için
zaten çağın ne hızına geçebiliyoruz,
ne de hazlarından haz alabiliyoruz.
O yüzden sürekli bir mutsuzluk
hali içerisindeyiz.
Bir huzursuzluk hali içindeyiz.
İnsanın fıtratına aykırı bir hızla
her şey aktığı için
onlara yetişme şansımız yok.
Yetişemediğimiz oranda
kendimizi geride kalmış,
geri kalmış , eksik hissediyoruz.
Hazlar üzerine kurulu bir dünyada ise
hazların sonu olmadığı,
tekrarlanırsa bile insana itminan
yani bir tatmin
duygusuna ulaştırmadığı için
sürekli bir mutsuzluk ve huzursuzluk
hali içerisinde bulunuyoruz.
Halbuki insanın,
narsistleşmeden kendini sevebilmesi,
kimseyi aşağılamadan ve hor görmeden
kendine güvenebilmesi,
Kimseden nefret etmeden,
Kimseyi hor görmeden,
kendine saygı duyabilmesi gerekir.
Narsizm tuzağına düşmeden
kendimizi bilmek,
kendimizi sevmek,
kendimize güvenmek ve
kendimize saygı duymak.
Bu dengeyi kurabildiğimiz oranda
kendi iç huzurumuz
evrendeki huzurla, ahenkle
ittihad eder, birleşir.
O zaman kendimizle, başka varlıklarla,
diğer toplumlarla, diğer insanlarla,
tırnak içinde ötekiyle kavga etmek yerine
birlikte yol yürümenin
imkanlarını araştırmaya başlarız.
Bunu yapabildiğimiz oranda da
kendimizi beğeni kültürünün
bir metası haline
getirmek yerine, kendi hakikatimizi
gerçekleştirmek için
kendimize başka bir yol seçeriz.
Eskiden ayna çok yaygın bir alet değildi.
Belki kadim toplumların pek çoğunda
milyonlarca insan hayatlarında
kendilerini bir defa bile aynada görmeden
bu dünyadan göçüp gitmişlerdi.
Ayna yaygınlaştı , kendimiz
aynada bakar hale geldik.
Hele bugün, hepimizin yanında taşıdığı
akıllı telefonlar, ekranlar üzerinden
kendimize onlarca, yüzlerce,
milyonlarca defa bakıyoruz.
Aynada baktığınızda ne görüyorsunuz?
Gördüğünüz şeyden memnun musunuz?
Mutlu musunuz?
Gördüğünüz şey sizin gördüğünüz şey mi?
Başkalarının beğenisi için kendinizi
soktuğunuz bir maske mi?
Bir başka kılık kıyafet mi?
Beğeni kültürü, bu beğeni açlığı
hastalığından kurtulmak için de
bizim aslında aynada
kendimize fiziki değil
fiziğin ötesindeki entellektüel, manevi,
ahlaki, estetik güzelliğimizi, manevi
manada estetiği kastediyorum
görmeyi öğrenmemiz gerekiyor.
Bazen insanlar geliyorlar
siz de karşılaşıyorsunuzdur,
Sizi makamıyla, mevkisi ile, parasıyla,
yatıyla, katıyla etkilemeye çalışıyorlar.
Ben de onlara diyorum ki,  ″ Beni böyle
şeylerle etkilemeyin, etkileyemezsiniz. ″
Beni aklınla etkile.
Beni zekanla etkile.
Beni kalbinle etkile.
Beni yaptığın güzel bir işle etkile.
Ortaya koyduğun güzel bir işle etkile.
Bir iyilikle.
Bir sanatla, bir yetenekle etkile.
Samimiyetinle, adanmışlığınla etkile.
Bunlar için maddi zenginliğe gerek yok.
Tam tersine bunları yaptığınız oranda
kendinize olan sevginiz, saygınız
ve öz güveniniz narsisizme, başkalarına
karşı haksızlığa dönüşmeden
size bir yol açacaktır.
Narkissos’tan nergise doğru
giderken
bu yolda, attığımız her adım
bir ışığa dönüşürse,
kurduğumuz ünsiyet, bağ
bizi başkalarıyla birlikte çoğaltırsa
o zaman nergislerde mutlu olur.
Teşekkür ederim.